okay welcome back everybody okay good so
today I'm going to talk about fast
Fourier transforms to solve PD's which
is gonna be a lot of fun because all
we're gonna do is in matlab and we're
gonna get pictures and see lots of cool
stuff
remind me homework 3 was not easy it was
a slim lot difficult and time-consuming
how long would you say it would take on
average 10 hours more than 10 hours ok
so I'm assuming that you would like an
easier homework 4 ok good so I'll put
out homework for today and it'll be
easier it won't be like obvious it won't
be trivial but it'll be easier so I
already have a homework 4 written I
wrote it this morning and I'm trying to
decide whether or not to put it in one
last problem but this is a pretty
straightforward homework where we're
essentially benchmarking how long the
FFT takes for different size vectors not
too difficult ok I might add a problem
where we benchmark how accurate the
derivative is if you do it using the FFT
but that's also what I'm doing in
lecture today so that would also be
pretty easy ok good unfortunately or
fortunately depending on how you see it
this is only 10 weeks for this entire
quarter for PDEs and numerical methods
and all this stuff if there was an
entire additional 10 weeks I would teach
you a whole course on numerical methods
to solve PDEs because I think that
that's probably the most important way
we could fill another course but as it
is I might have one or two or three
lectures to tell you everything that I
think is most important about how to
actually compute PDEs on a computer in
MATLAB but just be aware that this is a
much much larger field I mean a really
large field this is probably one of the
biggest grow
areas of applied math in the last 30 or
40 years since we have faster computers
we are increasingly solving problems on
computers so Boeing and Airbus I think
about 20% of their fluid analyses that
they do for lift and drag and efficiency
and engine and all of this are done on
computers now instead of wind tunnels
now 20% doesn't seem like a lot but it's
a lot when you consider how much money
Boeing spends on research and
development
so other classes that you could that I
would most highly recommend for
numerical methods for engineering or a
math so they're mostly in the a math
department a math 581 and a math 582
just a show of hands how many of you
have already taken 581 how many are
currently taking 582 ok good
this one is especially good when Nathan
Cutts is teaching it he created this
course and wrote the book on the subject
and it's pretty awesome 581 is probably
a little more relevant to actually
solving PDEs numerically on a computer
but 582 is more interesting data methods
and then I would say that there's 10
other good solid applied math courses if
you want to know about computing
derivatives with Fourier transforms or
you know more details about linear
algebra differential equations that sort
of thing ok but it's a huge fields and
it's really of increasing importance a
particularly good book kind of
introductory book on the subject is
spectral methods in MATLAB by Lloyd
trottin it's a really really good book
it's short it's about 150 pages it's not
perfect but it's pretty good I think
Nathan cuts his book on Amazon is a
little better and it's only 40 dollars
ok good ok so we're going to do a bunch
of things in a computer today last time
we derived the the solution of the heat
distribution on an infinitely long thin
rod using Fourier transform
and now we're going to use two different
ways of actually solving this on a
computer okay and next week either
Monday or Wednesday I'm going to start
talking about Laplace transforms which
will kind of finish off what we're
learning about partial differential
equations okay so we might have three to
six more lectures on PDE s and then the
rest will be more data science so last
time we had our solution of our heat
equation was U of X and T so our
temperature at all points in space and
for forward time was equal to an
integral from minus infinity to infinity
this is a convolution integral and I was
convulsion a diffusion operator if you
will it was diffusing my my heat with my
initial temperature distribution so this
is e to the minus X minus y squared X
minus y quantity squared divided by 4
Alpha squared T quantity divided by 2
alpha root pi t times f of y DUI ok this
is just what we wrote down at the end of
last lecture so F of Y was my initial
temperature distribution this is just a
Gaussian diffusion kernel that spreads
out more and more in forward time so the
variance gets wider and wider in time
and this is a convolution integral of my
Gaussian with my function ok so let's
just code this up so I'm starting with
the nastier of the two expressions
because I want us to see how nice and
easy fast Fourier transforms are so
we're going to actually code up this
horrible convolution integral and I
don't relish doing this that we're going
to okay so we're gonna clear all clothes
all CLC and I'm going to create a
spatial grid from let's say minus 50 to
50 and I'm going to create some initial
temperature distribution and we're gonna
solve for the evolving temperature
using this equation in time so I want
length of a hundred I want a DX of maybe
I want 1,001 points so my DX is L
divided by n minus 1
maybe I'll just make it a thousand
points in / n X is a domain from minus L
over two in increments of DX - l / -
okay so - 50 - 50 in increments of
points 0.1 okay and I'm going to start
with an initial temperature distribution
that's just 0 zero times the size of X
and then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to make so I'm going to have this
function from minus fifty to fifty and
it's going to be zero except in the
middle I'm gonna make it equal to one
I'm gonna make a square wave from
something like minus 10 to 10 or minus
five to five I forget we'll see okay so
f of and I wrote this really quickly
this morning it's a little hacky but
you'll get the general idea so so L over
two is the middle of the domain and I
subtract L over ten divided by DX
- L over 2 plus L over ten divided by DX
so those indices should equal one Anna
plot X by F okay test Heat convolution
okay so this is my square wave from
let's see from minus 10 to 10 basically
kind of makes sense okay so we have zero
that had bumps up to some temperature 1
and then it goes back down to 0 now
remember our Fourier transform is
defined on an infinite domain this
integral is from minus infinity to
infinity and so I'm essentially choosing
my domain to be much much larger than
the kind of transient disturbance and
I'm making it go to 0 on the endpoints
so we're going to approximate this
infinite integral with a finite integral
this is not you know super kosher but
it's ok ok what else we need to do we
need to define a thermal diffusion
constant a alpha let's just pick 5 for
now and I'm going to have to create a
dummy variable Y for this convolution
I'm just going to say y equals x ok so
what I'm going to do is for every X in
this interval for every single one of
these X's I'm going to have to
approximate this convolution integral
make sense so for every fixed X x equals
minus 10 x equals 5 x equals 15 for
every fixed X I'm going to have to
create this vector from minus 50 to 50
times this vector of data fy4 minus 50
to 50 because that's where my domain is
defined I'm gonna adopt them add them up
x dy or DX so I'm going to post these
codes you can see what I'm doing and
convince yourself this is the
convolution I'm pretty sure this is the
convolution because it matches the fast
Fourier transform solution and I'm gonna
make a DT of point one so for K equals 1
to 100 this is 100 time steps I'm gonna
say time equals K times DT so times zero
time point one point two so on and then
for every single time step I'm gonna
have to compute this convolution
integral for every
my ex this is a really nasty nested
horrible expression so for J equals 1/2
the length of X so we had a dummy
variable name for X minus y last time
what do we call this C okay in that lab
that's X I see so I'm going to say for
this particular X right for J equals 1/2
the length of X I'm going to step for
every single value of X and I'm going to
try to compute this convolution integral
for that fixed X so for this particular
X C equals XJ minus my entire vector of
Y so C is a vector same size as X same
sizes Y my convolution G the G part of
this kernel is equal to 1 over 2 times a
times square root of pi times T times
the exponential of minus C squared
divided by 4 times a times a times T
that's I'm literally just saying you
know for all of the Y's from - 50 - 50 I
can create a vector of this Gaussian
okay and I'm using my dummy variable C
because it's easier to write than X
minus y okay that's G now you of j my
temperature at the Jade spatial location
is equal to the dot product of G with F
times DX this integral from minus 50 to
50 is the same as my dot product of my
two giant vectors times DX that kind of
makes sense should I maybe write this
out a little more clearly this is
something so I was explaining fast
Fourier transforms and PD used to my
wife yesterday / Brack
fist and two-story and I realized that
there was one critical piece of
information I didn't tell you which is
this L 2 integral norm is exactly like
taking the dot product of discretized
versions of these functions at discrete
points ok so if I have two functions F
and G okay G and F I could integrate
let's say this is from A to B I could
integrate from A to B times you know f
of X G of X DX but if I was going to
think like a Riemannian about this what
I would do is I would chop my X into a
bunch of little D X's and I would take
each of these function values and I
would create a big vector of F and a big
vector of G ok so this is very nearly
given by a big vector of F inner product
with a big vector of G times DX right
it's F 1 times G 1 times DX plus F 2
times G 2 times DX plus I have 3 times G
3 times DX buh-buh-buh-buh-buh like I
just add up each of these little
rectangles of the products and that very
nearly approximates this l2 integral so
I was telling you that this is an inner
product and it really looks almost
exactly like an inner product when you
chop up your function into a bunch of
discrete points ok
so that's just a long way to explain why
I'm computing this entire integral using
the dot product times DX
questions I should have told you this
weeks ago
okay does this kind of make sense if I
have a vectorized version of this at a
bunch of discrete points X or a bunch of
discrete points Y I'm a vectorized
version of F and a bunch of discrete
points Y from minus 50 to 50 and to
integrate them their product I just
multiply the two vectors point-wise and
I add them all up
times DX okay you can look at this later
you can convince yourself that this is
true so that's my function U at the
spatial location XJ is this dot product
of my Gaussian times my function times
DX and and I'm gonna plot X by U in
black and just to make it look nice I'm
gonna give it an axis of - L - L minus L
over 2 2 L over 2 and minus 0.1 21.1 and
I'm gonna pause 0.1 seconds every time I
get a new time step okay so that is the
basic idea of this program makes sense
for each DT for each point in time I
have a new time and for that time I go
through every spatial location from
minus 50 to 50 and I compute what this
convolution integral is at that
particular X so I get this whole
function U 4 - 50 - 50 and I plot it ok
and this is my thermal diffusion
operator acting in time now something
weird is happening it's taking a really
long time for we know that eventually
this should have some non-zero average
temperature but this is kind of bleeding
out to infinity so my domain is not
large enough to really simulate this
accurately but it works for small times
and for small eyes I think my thermal
diffusion was maybe to choose too
aggressive okay this makes sense and
it's physically intuitive what's
happening we took that square wave and
we're convolving it with a gaussian
which means we're diffusing this the
sharp corners we're diffusing everything
to its neighbors so this is being hit
with a diffusion operator and the
diffusion operator variance is
increasing with time okay but this was a
really nasty hard way to solve this
problem
so let's try to do it the easy way using
the fast Fourier transform okay good so
I'm going to use the same length the
same number of points the same DX same
spatial domain same function but instead
of solving this with a convolution I'm
going to solve it using the fast Fourier
transform so what did we find at the end
of last lecture if I wrote this in the
frequency domain what do I have for you
hat u hat of Omega and T what was you
had about my guarantee you can just tell
me in words doesn't have to be math
right G hat whatever the Fourier
transform of this nasty gash in is which
is a simple regression so this equals G
hat of Omega and T times well times that
phat just times that hat not kind of all
not convolution about that and since I'm
going to use a discrete Fourier
transform instead of a continuous
Fourier transform right in the computer
I can't do infinite integrals I can only
do discrete Fourier transforms I'm going
to get rid of this Omega and I'm gonna
call it K
so in discrete Fourier transform in DFT
K is my wave number and it takes the
same role as Omega it's basically the
discrete version of Omega
okay and I should write down what this G
hat is because it's important so G hats
of right so G hat was something like e
to the minus K squared alpha squared T
yeah simpler gumption this would have
been Omega squared in the last lecture
but now we're using a discrete Fourier
transform so I'm calling it Kappa okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
take my initial distribution F I'm gonna
Fourier transform it I'm going to
compute this Gaussian in the frequency
domain multiply them and inverse Fourier
transform this should be super simple
right FFT and I FFT are built in the
MATLAB really really fast really really
easy okay good so I'm gonna delete all
of this nonsense
alright so instead what we're going to
have to do is we're going to have to the
only trick the only difficult part of
this of doing this in the frequency
domain is making a vector of k's because
in MATLAB everything is a vector this
function is just a vector of values at
different K this function is just a
vector of values a different K and so I
have to figure out what this vector of K
wave numbers is and it's a little
complicated I've been trying to find a
good way to explain this and I'm sure I
will someday but basically I take my 2pi
divided by the length of my domain right
that's good
well now I'm quite worried yeah all
right let's just keep blindly proceeding
and see what happens
man okay let's call this Kappa okay so I
basically I'm gonna take increments of
two pi divided by L that's kind of my
smallest frequency that I have to work
with in this domain and then what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take multiples of
that I'm gonna take one two PI over L
two two PI's over L three two PI over L
for Q PI so far I'm gonna take all of
those 1 2 n 2 PI's over elbows and my
frequencies and because matlab's FFT
stores its frequencies in a weird order
I have to store my Kappas in a weird
order and this is a step I can't really
explain because I don't quite understand
why I have to do this but I do I've
tried everything to get around this
everything in the last two hours at
least and I couldn't do it I tried that
and that only works if you take the real
part in the answer so this gives me the
actual honest-to-goodness real valued
function and doing that doesn't okay but
let's try that in a minute so that's a
very good suggestion and it does kind of
work this also kind of works okay so I
create this K vector of frequencies it's
kind of like 2 PI over L 4 PI over L 6
PI over L dot I thought that thought
except it's been shifted and reorganized
in a funny way and you can always use
this line of code to build your K vector
in practice okay so now I have u hat
equals F hat should probably compute f
hat f hat equals fft of f
so you had his f hat dot times the
exponential of minus a squared times T
times Kappa squared okay
I am literally just point wise
multiplying G hat and F for every value
of K that's what dot times means it's
element wise multiplication okay and
then in real space all I do is I take
the IFFT of you hat I inverse Fourier
transform on back to the real space and
I can still plot X and u now we're going
to call this test heat FFT so instead of
using convolution we're using the fast
Fourier transform so if this works
something terrible happens size of Kappa
size of F
okay
okay sorry shouldn't do live demos what
is capa
oh yeah sorry my ex should be from the -
DX here there you go
sorry the codon line is going to be
correct okay so this is exactly the same
solution except now we're doing it using
the fast Fourier transform and so we
never have to compute this nasty
convolution integral which is beneficial
for a number of reasons first of all we
had to compute this horrible dot product
for every value of x so we had this kind
of nested for loop which was really
really nasty right for every single one
of my values of X I had to do this big
computation but if I do this in the
frequency domain I'm basically just
taking the dot product of you know I'm
multiplying two vectors a single time
and I get my answer and then I inverse
Fourier transform okay questions about
this code and what's happening let's try
Ben's suggestion and do a different
version of Kappa let's try Kappa equals
something much more like what we expect
to have so in the discrete so how many
of you have actually watched the
lectures on the FFT and the DFT for
image compression okay good I would
recommend you Washington if you haven't
it's important so we have something like
e to the I Omega terms and this Omega is
like two PI over L this is a very good
notation times some number n as our
basic frequencies and so we're gonna
have two times pi divided by L times I
think I want to go 1 to n X but because
MATLAB stores its frequencies in FFT in
a weird order it doesn't store them in
the same orders as 1 to n it stores them
like 1 2 n over 2 and then mine
does some we were shifting something
called FFT shift so there's an FFT shift
command I can say Kappa equals FFT shift
of Kappa so this will get me in the same
index notation as MATLAB and all of this
should work except now I have to take
the real part for some reason oh no that
didn't work
- an x over 2 to n x over 2 like that
that works okay good and let's see if I
actually needed to do this real parts
mat level complaint okay okay good so
apparently was much simpler than I was
making it and it actually does work so
so what MATLAB is doing there's two
things that it's doing we are working on
a domain - 50 - 50 which is good but if
we were working on a domain 0 to L when
you take the FFT of a vector of you know
your function you don't ever give MATLAB
the X range you don't ever tell it what
it's defined over you never give it X
you just give it F and so MATLAB assumes
that what you have is the same exact
function but defined for - L over 2 - L
over 2 so the exact same function but it
is going to just represent it in a way
from minus L over 2 to L over Q because
it doesn't know what X domain you're
working on and then it also shifts the
frequencies so that instead of going
from minus L over 2 to L over 2 I think
it goes from 0 to L over 2 and then
minus L over 2 to 0 and FFT shift shifts
them back and it's doing this to make to
save time it's faster to do it this way
for some reason okay good
sure it is affirmed for minus PI to PI
and were stretching PI over 2 yeah okay
good so this code is much better than
like 18 and 19 is a much better way to
do this because it actually kind of
makes sense right we think that our
frequencies go from minus and of minus
NX over to 2 NX over 2 in increments of
2 PI over L my fundamental frequency and
I have two FFT shift to get into
into matlab's FFT index notation okay
good and that's my diffusion equation
minus one so I like to always take a DX
off of one side so that it's and I don't
know and so I'm really not like the best
expert on this I usually inherit codes
from other people that are really really
good at this and then I use them for the
data but my gut feeling is that if you
have a function defined on you know
minus L over 2 to L over 2 and it's
periodic you might want to only include
one of the endpoints and so I'm just
subtracting a DX on the right hand side
and I'm only going to one minus the top
frequency on the right hand side it
doesn't really matter in practice if you
get rid of this DX and if you don't
change it below I just did for this code
again this is the kind of thing you
would learn in a whole course and it's
all in here I'm showing you kind of the
simple implementations of this stuff
okay so there is another code I want to
show you called test heat both and
basically I just want to convince you
that if I do the convolution integral
and the FFT I get basically the same
answer okay because we've been doing the
same thing two different ways so let's
try that so they pretty much agree for a
long time now eventually they start to
disagree on the steady state value
because they're kind of having different
assumptions about what's happening at
the infinite conditions they're just
handling their hand they're both
mathematically handling everything to
the left of minus 50 in the right of
minus 50 differently so if I wanted them
to agree better for longer I could make
a bigger domain and it would work better
okay
the basic idea is that we can do
computations in the frequency domain you
know lots of computations are easier
convolution as much easier taking the
derivative is much easier and then we
can inverse Fourier transform and it's
extremely fast in MATLAB so how fast is
a fast Fourier transform and log N and Y
is n log N and what how fast is the
discrete Fourier transform and squared
okay why is n log n better than N
squared smaller by basically N and the
great thing about n log n is that you
call this asymptotically linear which
means as n gets bigger and log n looks
even better because the log n becomes
relatively smaller right like log n of
10 trillion 13 right log n of 10
trillion is just a very small number and
so the bigger end gets the more linear
and log n looks ok which is great
because we like bigger and bigger
problems ok any questions about this
general idea of solving this FF this
heat equation using either convolution
or FFT yeah yeah I can actually write
you hat dot equals alpha squared u hat
times K squared is there - there's
probably a - like that no I could take
this OTE and I could solve it using our
case OD 45 I could solve this using OD
45 where u is a big vector of you know
or where K is a big vector of
frequencies and where I have some
initial data u naught and I could then
take each of those solutions for every
time an inverse Fourier transform that
would be totally fine
I'm just analytically I'm just writing
the analytic
solution of this you hat equals you know
e to the lambda T you hat not because I
want to do one thing at a time
yeah but that's a really good point you
could if I took my PDE my partial
differential equation and I Fourier
transform it I get an OD e in MATLAB we
have really powerful tools solve OD OD
45 they're very accurate they're really
easy to implement and I could actually
solve this OD e in time in the frequency
domain using ode45 and then I could take
my solution and I FFT that so that's a
really good point I do plan on doing
that
but I plan on doing that kind of at the
end of the class when I have a little
more time yeah so we're gonna do this
for like nasty or more nonlinear
problems where I don't know what the
solution is to the OD e really good good
question
okay other questions
okay so I'm expecting you're actually
going to need to try out this code and
play with it and run it yourself a while
okay so the next thing I want to do the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to use the FFT to approximate a
derivative okay
so remind me if I have a function f of X
and I want to take its derivative d/dx
and I take the Fourier transform of that
what do I get right I Omega times the
Fourier transform of f of X which is I
Omega F hat of them again I think it's
positive I Omega okay and so if I was
going to do the same thing with a
discrete Fourier transform I would
basically say that this is I K times the
FFT of f of X not the ffff the FFT okay
same basic idea okay so let's take a
function I'm gonna define it with 101
points on a domain of eight pi because I
want it to be periodic and I'm going to
use sines and cosines so DX is going to
be L divided by n minus 1 X is equal to
minus L over 2 and increments of DX 2l
over 2 minus DX and the function I'm
going to choose is cosine of X times the
exponential of minus x squared divided
by 25 so basically cosine times the
Gaussian let's see we're gonna test
back Terral derivative so first of all
let's just plot this and X is a big
vector so it should be dot to the power
Q I want to take the square of every
element of X ok so this is my function
I'm gonna take the derivative of it
ok luckily I can analytically compute
the derivative DF is equal to minus sine
of X times exponential minus x squared
divided by 25 plus 2 over 25 times X dot
times cos x dot times exponential minus
x squared divided by 25 this is just the
chain rule and I can plot X by DF in
black this is the derivative of my
function this is the analytic
honest-to-goodness derivative of my
function I did it by hand okay now
how did we what are some ways we can
compute the derivative of a vector of
values of a function f we've learned a
couple waves not just this fast Fourier
transform lets a simpler way find a
difference right I can just take the
finite difference of all of these points
so let's code up a crude find out
difference just to compare okay I'm
gonna hold my plot and we're going to
approximate derivative using finite
difference okay so for K equals 1/2 the
length of my vector F I'm going to say
that my derivative my derivative of F
finite difference is equal to well this
is just F at k plus 1 minus F of K
divided by a DX
I'm using a forward difference and the
tricky thing about forward differences
is that you can't use them on the
forward right most end point and so I'm
gonna use a backward difference and it's
gonna look exactly the same but at the
end point doesn't really matter to me
right now okay and I'm gonna plot this
finite difference in a blue dash line
pretty good right agrees pretty well for
the DX that I chose this is a small DX
and I have like a hundred points that's
decent ok now let's try our spectral
derivative so whenever you take the
derivative using the fast Fourier
transform or in the frequency domain we
call it the spectral derivative it
sounds super cool okay so what are the
steps to compute a spectral derivative
in MATLAB what do I have to do what are
we taking the derivative of
taking the derivative of that so we have
to Fourier transform hat then what do we
do we have to Fourier transform F then
we multiply it by I K where K is a
vector of frequencies then what inverse
Fourier transform three steps okay so f
hat equals FFT of F I'm gonna create my
K vector and I'm going to take the K
vector from here which I like a lot
better than what I have
so Kappa ok and now I'm going to say D F
hat my derivative hat is equal to I
times K Kappa dot times F hat just I
times K times f hat and then finally my
derivative in my derivative is the IFFT
of the hat derivative and finally I'm
going to plot X with DF FFT and read ok
and then let's just make sure this runs
of course it does except it has some
real and imaginary parts so I'm just
gonna make the real part okay so you
can't really tell which ones doing
better right off the bat so I'm going to
zoom in I'm also going to label my axis
from minus L over 2 to L over 2 minus 1
to 1 and legend is gonna say true
derivative finite difference and FFT
derivative
so now if i zoom in you can see right
off the bat that the red and the black
curves the true derivative and the FFT
derivative are almost perfectly
overlaying each other and the blue curve
has some error write it over predicts on
positive slopes under predicts on
negative slopes we know this from the
finite difference but the FFT derivative
is extraordinarily close in fact I can
just keep going and it's just almost
perfect
all right SuperDuper close this is a
hundred points this is a pretty coarse
DX right my domain is from basically
it's eight pi length with a hundred
points so this FFT derivative is pretty
easy to compute and it's extraordinarily
accurate any ideas why this might be
accurate or maybe another question why
is finite difference not okay why is
finite difference not accurate
even if I use central difference that
would still have error
so this finite differences order Delta
access terrible yeah super crude central
difference would be order Delta x
squared if I wanted to make my finite
difference higher order accurate what
would I have to do I'd have to use more
points on either side I'd have to use a
larger stencil of points so part of why
my finite difference is inaccurate is
because I'm only looking at a very small
neighbor of points around where I'm
taking the derivative and I'm using that
to estimate what the what the curvature
is what the derivative is and if I used
a larger and larger radius of points I
would get a more and more accurate
scheme well when we fast Fourier
transform we're essentially like each of
these frequencies for each Kappa I have
a sine wave that covers all my points
and so in some way doing this derivative
in the frequency domain is like taking a
stencil that uses all of the points in
your domain it's kind of the best you
could possibly do using all of the
points on that domain because you're
doing this analytically this is an
analytic expression we did this by hand
this is the this isn't an approximation
this is the actual true derivative and
essentially we're taking all of the data
points that we have access to into
account when we do this okay so it's
like an infinite stencil or stencil on
all of your data points okay now another
thing we can do is essentially wrap a
big loop around this and so instead of
just looking at 101 points I can look at
10 points 20 points 40 860 320 I can
just look at a broad range of
discretization points and see how much
better does this get with more points so
let's do that
pretty sure I called this something like
benchmark spectral derivative okay so
now what we're gonna do is I'm going to
create I'm gonna keep a record of what
my finite difference error is and I'm
going to keep a record of what my fast
Fourier transform
error is for all of these n values so
I'm gonna have this discretization for
eight points 16 32 all the way up to
4096 and this code runs super fast ish
and what we find is the red points this
is on a log scale so this is 10 to the 0
that's order 1 error this is 10 to the
minus 10 that's one tenth of a billion
one tenth of a 1 over 10 billion error
and this red curve is my fast Fourier
transform derivative error and the blue
curve is my finite difference error okay
so we start to see right off the bat
with 16 points my FFT is doing better
than my finite difference ever could and
as I increase the number of points I can
basically drive this down to machine
precision I can go all the way to 10 to
the minus 16 if I want so this is what
people use when they're simulating fluid
flows over airplane wings
they don't use finite differences they
do sometimes there's better fancy
fancier things you can do but most of
the time they use spectral methods they
use the Fourier transform to their
advantage not only because it's faster
it is faster it's not faster than this
but it's faster than other larger
stencils like central difference and you
know larger stencils but because it's
way way way more accurate for the same
number of points okay
questions about this yeah yeah I'm glad
your ass there are certainly times where
this wouldn't work very well this works
for smooth functions
this works for really nice smooth
functions so I have something called
smooth FFT derivative and it should be
called not smooth FFT derivative because
I'm going to do this on I'm not some new
function I should have closed all clear
at all on CL seed okay so now I'm going
to take the fast Fourier transform
derivative of this function which is a
hat forward difference would nail this
forward difference would be perfect at
all of these points until right there
and at all of these points until right
there right forward difference to be
perfect
at most points this is what the Fourier
transform derivative gives me totally
sucks
right it really sucks because this is
not a smooth function it's not well
approximated by a few low frequency sine
waves it's approximated only if I keep
all of my sine waves at very high
frequency so it's really really noisy
and nasty so this is not good for
capturing shock waves or you know really
really short discreet events it's not
good for capturing fractures and
materials it's not good for capturing
any kind of discontinuities so you have
hybrid schemes for for shock capturing
let's say I make my and a lot bigger I
make it 200 well now it looks a lot
better except I get this horrible Gibbs
phenomenon ringing at the
discontinuities okay so these are the
pitfalls of using the fast fourier
transform for derivatives it works for
smooth functions extraordinarily well
not so much for other functions okay
that was a lot to cover I want you to go
back and look at the codes and try these
out this is not supposed to be one-shot
and it's completely understandable next
week we're going to talk about Laplace
transforms and we're gonna come back to
numerix and data in about five or six
lectures
thank you